[Music]
yourself quitter you're just gonna poop
myself I was hoping I wasn't the only
one in this room that shoots them at
your all behind the scenes right damn it
one of these days you guys are gonna
[ __ ] your pants like a child
here we go off the record I think Bart's
with Bart you [ __ ] on yourself right
that's you dude
somebody's with weren't you about to
take a sh in their bushes yes I have the
footage I've seen it's a process I was
going home he panicked [ __ ] went in
any way whoo music and I have to check
my ass cuz I thought I [ __ ] myself and
then and then he smelled it I had to
smell my hand okay here we go hey guys
welcome back to off-the-record or we
talk about what we want and we already
started yeah off the record off the
record we have nothing else to talk
about ever like now what I'm saying is
cold that's what I would put this on you
say I need to go take a poop right I
need to take a poop right now I gotta
take a poop right I gotta put this on
right now
that smells like I gotta take a look
right now that's what you've got to
prove myself I'm just a child I [ __ ]
love that [ __ ] me too
no it's like fart jokes and poop jokes
they never get old dick jokes all of it
when someone who would clearly not poop
themselves says they're gonna poop
now you're like now it's their turn why
can't it went clearly op Hoover so it's
like a nice looking lady
keep put together yeah kind of people
put themselves know only when I was a
kid that was the only time I was 3 years
old and I was so embarrassed that's
because you don't test yourself yeah you
don't you don't push the limits schedule
ok after coffee in the morning it's
every time and that's it just once but
haven't I never I do that too but
haven't you had your coffee and you go I
gotta fart and then you go you know and
then down the back of your legs and all
over your shoes the first time I shot it
wasn't tell me this story has a female
relationship the hits just keep on
coming
you gotta tell us the story as a female
not as a male so as a female we want to
know what happened before the shot so
what's the feeling what's the state over
there yes so when we're at our old way
to your house mm-hmm
I was on the dining table long have you
been dating him on the dining table well
I was sitting by the dining how long
have you been dating at this point I
think she was already moved in oh you
still got embarrassed because it was my
first time shooting all cuz you
literally said I was so embarrassed
cause he's a human being I was in
empowers embarrassed I was an
embarrassed that she witnessed that I
was embarrassed of my own pride by his
own self okay so at the time tommy was
doing some computer stuff in the other
room jess was in the kitchen area and
then you know I was eating breakfast and
I got up and then I I you know like we
fart in front of each other and it's
funny and I just ripped one out when it
came out was like oh [ __ ] literally I
think I [ __ ] myself I gotta go I gotta
go
and then she was like oh my god you
sharted I said Tommy like oh he gambled
any loss I ran up to the bathroom by
myself
yeah so it happened right then and there
and I wasn't expecting how much of it
came out oh not a lot Joey that lesson
it was it was like it was like this okay
wasn't that much
but imagine if there was like a [ __ ]
plugging the [ __ ] and in the popular
air came out anyway and it just popped
the bottle cap from yesterday the bottle
wet it was a little wet so it was like
it was like it was soft Oh a bit like a
bubble of shower water bottle yeah yeah
it was like that's basically it anyway
right
oh no why did you tell her he doesn't
keep secrets dude cuz I'm not a liar
it's a good secret to keep some secrets
are pretty good man did he walk to the
bathroom like there's no way she but
this is a lesson Joe and for everyone
else says does this [ __ ] violating
ass [ __ ] behavior you're supposed to
go to the bathroom yeah I'm a fart but
it feels so uncomfortable it also might
just be a digestion issue
I got it's trying to prevent the guys
from farting why you have pieces of poo
and like right but that's already I got
I got IBS and in the morning he told you
like you're stupid
I got idea like it's a badge you can go
in an occupied occupied
that's true you can commandeer other
people's clothes you don't like those
restaurants that don't have any bathroom
for like yeah I should just hop over the
counter it's okay baby services we
appreciate what you do should be [ __ ]
emoji yeah yeah it was like going good
it should smart we should have an IBS
card because well help me you would have
I bet you a lot of other people with IBS
will have it lay in this room Bobby Lee
Bobby Lee [ __ ] from his own car I would
try to figure out a way a little pool to
get that car yeah don't have a handicap
but they have the handicap placard it's
like it's like the medical marijuana
cards before it was leaving yeah yeah
you had to like make up a story you know
well sometimes I [ __ ] and I didn't know
my buddy my buddy dude one time my buddy
like like so we were trying to park at
my old apartment complex that used to
take forever to find a parking spot so
then where we are pulling into a parking
lot and the guy pulls into it like right
in front of us just takes our spot why
would it take and yeah he could have not
seen us who the [ __ ] knows I don't know
my buddy we were past brother [ __ ] you
dude or whatever so you [ __ ] on his car
my buddy can't leave it at that
he goes inside the house really he
filled we had we came back with Panda
Express he takes the bag into the
bathroom all shits into the bag and he
[ __ ] dogs
pretty crazy [ __ ] on the rent ready to
go yeah he's that guy back he's somebody
could [ __ ] on command yeah he do my
thing was I can't feel it in the bag my
[ __ ] will just be all stuck on the sides
I could like not happy to chat off but
when I was a kid if I got locked out of
the house or the car or I got kind of
scared at all I just go [ __ ] in a bush
because I just quit like feel in a bush
but I never [ __ ] myself how old are you
I'm like 10 that's pretty much key kid
so I would have to come home you know
alone and I sometimes I forgot the key
in the house and so I'd be locked out
and then I'd be like oh no when's the
next time I can use a toilet I don't
know I bet just shot yeah yeah cuz you
immediately have to [ __ ] there's your
commit yeah that's what I was thinking I
was like how the only time I've ever
been able to is when I feel scared like
my life's in danger it becomes like like
that the toilet ya know this dude after
he it was like a rocking training
montage
he went like instantly as soon as he
finishes one of the bad line revenge
movie dia yeah I reminds me that South
Park where they eat PF Changs and they
[ __ ] like the Polish shits that they can
come and then he like it has the biggest
shin it sways like five Katie Couric's
oh come on I've only ever peed on myself
I've never [ __ ] on myself you peed
yourself yeah when that happened uh well
the last time it happened it was like
what are we talking about peeing
ourselves as adults it's embarrassing
well why did you pee under someone 15 I
told you guys this is because we were a
big bear and I was wearing one of those
like the cloth belts that have the
initials in the front portion why yeah
oh you couldn't take it off myself cuz I
was in the port-a-potty I couldn't take
it off [ __ ] and then I just I ended up
just gone and then so I tried playing it
off so I got all this snow on top of my
pants and I'm like oh no there's no
melting on me I love just coming out of
the bathroom and then be like [ __ ]
snow there's actual photos because I was
playing with my cousin in the snow and
then you could see with peace till we're
sure yeah just sit right here no no
we're the same age oh we're the same age
and so and so I can smell all this snow
I had all this snow on my pants in the
photo but you could clearly see like a
piece it was a perfect horseshoe yes it
was so you need to put the snow all
around here yeah
smart enough at least it was warm no
dude that was the last time I peed on
myself though that was really
embarrassing I was like when I was 15 I
moved back in with my dad and that's
when we're trying to reconnect our
relationship we didn't really talk
they're divorced and for some reason my
dad has like this low Rumble voice so
I'd be home I just watching TV and I
think he really wanted to connect so he
would come into my room and he likes to
sit there and I try to talk to your dad
or whatever and after about a good
minute or two
I think the rumbly voice just makes me
wanna [ __ ] dad you coming in with the
[ __ ] deep lumps you could have kept
the door open while you had a
conversation are you taking a [ __ ] loud
shits though you know every [ __ ] [ __ ]
like when it first starts the [ __ ]
drop the gas part of it or even the
budget spread to it's already dad the
frequency of your voice just [ __ ] I
grabbed one side because I want it to
come out smooth so I grabbed one side
and you'll hear my butt cheek like well
that's a one side of toilet see if I
pull the other side what's like really
stuck on and then you have to use that
[ __ ] I've never heard of anyone
spreading their ass in trouble done
trouble that's why you need stuff about
their bathrooms why does it does anyone
turn on the faucet while they [ __ ] yeah
yeah that's a waste of water I don't
want to waste water bro oh [ __ ] you guys
I don't care but she wants to waste
water
I'm sure the fan dog or the fan noise to
get the white noise thing no I don't
mind hearing him [ __ ] cuz I'm just like
cool yeah it's just funny after all I
know purpose I'd like start answering
those noises I'm like what do you say
stop doing that now he's aware that I'm
listening yeah there's an old nervous
yeah he's is boho clothes he's like
whitening his but more
start doing it basic stop stop I did
have the craziest diarrhea yesterday
Jesus that's when I wished I had the
squatty potty but you can actually kind
of get in that position I remember us
flexing my castle [ __ ] offered you
need metal rings dude in email rings the
thing that you hold on the side of the
car [ __ ] forearms
[Laughter]
enough of those lol oh yeah yeah
[ __ ] clinch that [ __ ] and drive it
down restroom were with silver ship
every oh yeah oh my god it's funny how
we could talk forever about [ __ ] yeah
got our [ __ ] experiences we can do a
podcast about what you know a podcast
should they do tell you [ __ ] they do
tell you nothing but [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] show
everyone's doing podcast now we should
have people from every background and
every race and creating color and
religion come in and talk about how they
are they should we should write a book
called everybody poops
oh they have that already really oh my
gosh it's that idea that's in our
bathroom in the downtown LA office yeah
I'm too serious when I don't uh it's not
the same thing it's opposite of me I'm
telling the truth and then her mom
thinks I'm joking and then when you're
joking they think it's serious yeah all
the time I'm like oh I think cuz you
have one expression note mm-hmm so then
you can't tell I'm not a comedian
well you gotta so you gotta do a little
more zip on your sarcasm yeah and then
or make a little expression a facial
expression that's like mmm no because
then that's when it's like oh she got
butthurt now she's trying to joke back
yet but well they already built a brand
for you they're like no matter what TIFF
says it's serious and she's lecturing to
if you should do the pop art yeah
I want to play a game where we all
agreed that if bored ever opens up to us
we laugh at him and we should try to
everybody
oh it's really fun so different than now
but the thing is he's so open you guys
just don't even know it's all [ __ ]
far left you're just like that gotta be
a joke that's the way go back to here
what nothing that you do open up you say
the door swings so far open yeah it just
sounds so crazy that people are like
that's not not I can't be real but it's
very true oh and he's very fun
would you like to open up to us right
number no baby I'm remind me that we
can't wait to laugh at you your
childhood perhaps yeah growing up alone
stop you that's really tough how was
your parents divorce
you sound pretty good my mom restraining
order people are just waiting to get
revenge because you burn up when they
open up burn what they open up do they
but I appreciate that because those are
insecurities those are funny your
insecurities are hilarious but then you
make me not be insecure about it anymore
because you make me see how ridiculous
they are see that's life no now you're
gonna keep being an [ __ ] no no I
can't if it doesn't work on there
anymore
like I can trust your ears anymore
didn't give a [ __ ] about it's all my
[ __ ] I need to figure out something else
bar it's bullying for a good cause or we
need to prove to her that her ears
really are big using science and
evidence and graphs and charts you see
here's a regular face tip here's what a
year should look like bridge America
here diameter actually larger an entire
PowerPoint presentation and this is a
Keebler elves n it to you and this is
your face yeah we should get a scientist
to come in and explain do your ears
really are that bigger we have an ear
doctor yeah oh my god Nikki was telling
me about that party that you guys went
to I you did presentations oh yeah
Valentine's Day party so our friend has
he has themed parties every holidays
Christmas New Year's yeah it's really
fun but on Valentine's Day every year
they do PowerPoint presentations and you
could make a PowerPoint presentation
about anything last time yeah so ever
you get to pick a random topic and make
PowerPoint presentation sounds fun but
they didn't think that Steve and I would
do it so they didn't tell us so we even
got there yeah that would be too cool
like what the [ __ ] we would love that
yeah I mean I am very cool so I know I
know I presenter you know seems like you
think you're too cool to wear clothes
I'm just cold
I know you are what was your
presentation I get my laziness mistaken
as too cool sometimes too yes me so we
last minute through hours together at
the party there at where there was a
laptop there so we like we're
last-minute throwing us together mine
was about the movie flight and I
basically brought up all of Steve's
talking points that he talks about every
single day to me but I brought him up as
if I'm the first person ever think of
them I was like nobody ever talks about
this it is not said enough
they're trolleys and then at the last
minute I had a picture of who it was
like this could also be titled
conversations I have with my husband
every day and the nice boy it was like
every single day I love the movie flight
I will stand by Wednesday Thursday the
movie flight is incredible one of the
greatest things about them God is big
every day movie is about is my daily one
we blew the plane and wall under the
influence does it influence any use
cocaine so and alcohol you use alcohol
and then use cocaine to balance himself
out what do you know what
you have been able to land the plane had
he not been that's what the movies about
are those influences
I think it's ballsy to make a movie
about that as a former drug dealer
though there are tweakers that use weed
to calm down and balance themselves
uppers downers all also interviewed a
heroin at an ex heroin addict who used
weed to get off of heroin so it was a
gateway out that's it nobody talks your
presentation about mine was about
extremely backlit hair in music videos
in the 1980s and the rise and fall of
extremely backed up hair and like the
the dangers and how they pushed it too
hard
what was the danger Michael Jackson's
hair caught on fire every service during
the Pepsi day they back let the [ __ ]
[ __ ] out of his hair what did they use
lighter fluid in his hair dude I don't
know it was crazy so you know how they
used to in all 80s music videos yeah
they have extremely like all the heart
music videos yeah and like all the
[ __ ] how would you told me that I
immediately pictured everything so yeah
and Bonnie Tyler and all that [ __ ] total
clips you could barely even see your
faces
[ __ ] hairs backlit so hard so yeah
and then it was about how like the
lumens that they lit their hair with
like you couldn't you can light up to
1,200 lumens but hd's back then and
these people were pushing up to 22,000
lumens that must have been [ __ ] hot
that's very hot so then Mike it all
ended with Michael Jackson and then
that's why now when you watch like music
videos throughout the 90s they like the
foreground they like the back they light
everything like you look at a Backstreet
Boys music video it's the most it's like
lit like an Apple store because they had
the early 2000s but they had to figure
that and the lights back then were
really hot very hot really hot very
Dean's it even had these you should with
him yeah I know he's behind man yeah I
would just be like and back then [ __ ]
about saving energy
[Applause]
[Music]